back it is now a quarter past five here
at eight news now we know life is more
expensive it's more expensive for you
more expensive for us to help give back
though eight news now has partnered with
albertsons to help gift you a good day
every week we're surprising one lucky
shopper and helping pay for their
groceries let's take a look at how i
surprised one albertson's shopper
[Music]
i met rachel at the albertsons in east
las vegas she told me prices for
everything has been a pain in her pocket
even though i'm retired military it
still pinches us i mean in the checkbook
so it's been very very challenging
because i know i i look at everything
on the shelves and how much they cost
and they have gone up so much to where
there's no way we can afford to go out
and live our lives because i want to go
out and buy more groceries only thing is
i know how much they cost so it's hard
to fill the pantry
that's when albertsons and 8 news now
decided it was time to gift rachel a
good day i would like to gift you your
groceries oh my goodness wow what a
blessing that is good yes help pay for
your groceries this morning wow that is
fantastic thank you very much
she was very appreciative she was
wonderful she she did get by the way our
fake credit card for the record just so
you know had a great time surprising her
you never know when you could be next
just keep an eye out for the good day
team and you might be surprised just
like she was as we gift people good days
uh sometimes those big credit cards are
a little hard to handle you know you
can't just like swipe it it's hard to
put in your wallet yeah
you can't even use it on the tap part no
nothing happens
no but it was great to surprise her
obviously like everybody else that we've
been talking to you know it's it's a
challenge right now things are so
expensive so even if it doesn't cover
everything the the a little bit that we
can help which we think is a pretty fair
amount yeah it goes a long way we're
glad to be able to do it yeah she was
very pleasant she was fun yeah you never
know who you're going to meet too
there's so many interesting stories from